salut à tous bienvenue à bruxelles nous
sommes au parlement européen pour une
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo dans
cette émission direction malmö en suède
là bas comme partout ailleurs en europe
la communauté juive vit dans un climat
d'insécurité permanent surtout depuis
les attentats de paris et de copenhague
les écoles et lieux de culte sont sous
protection policière et face à ce
constat de nombreuses familles
s'interroge doivent-elles quitté la
suède et partir en israël et comment
agir pour retisser du lien entre les
communautés ce sera notre reportage mais
d'abord l'actualité la commission
européenne claironne depuis quelques
jours c'est la fin des taxes ruling ces
ristournes que des entreprises négocié
auprès des états pour leurs impôts
faut-il y croire pas sûr c'est la
question de la semaine et elle est
signée simon barbare et
la coupe est pleine l'opacité dans la
fiscalité des entreprises en europe
pierre moscovici n'en veut plus fini les
scandales comme ceux du luxe knicks ces
accords secrets qui ont permis à des
multinationales comme apple ikea ou
amazon de bénéficier de la fiscalité
très arrangeante du luxembourg pays du
président de la commission avec pour
conséquence des milliards d'euros de
perdus pour les états membres où ces
entreprises réalisent est vraiment leurs
bénéfices la commission européenne donc
proposé de rendre obligatoires les
échanges d'informations entre autorités
fiscales nationales la transparence
entre états c'est bien mais la
transparence vis-à-vis du public ce
serait peut-être mieux on sait que les
grandes multinationales sont très
soucieuses de leur image et une image de
proder pourrait avoir un impact sur leur
chiffre d'affaires au même moment à
francfort les manifestations tournent à
l'émeute devant le nouveau siège de la
banque centrale européenne des dérapages
que regrettent les organisateurs de ce
rassemblement contre les mesures
d'austérité il faut dire que ce nouveau
palais de verre a coûté la bagatelle de
plus d'un milliard d'euros symbole d'un
fossé qui sépare les institutions
européennes des citoyens tout pouvoir
d'achat de plus en plus faible alors
peut-on croire les promesses de
transparence de la commission
la commission européenne qui vante la
transparence ça fait longtemps qu'on
l'attend c'est un petit peu ce serpent
de mer dont on entend parler depuis pas
mal de temps et pour en parler c'est
philippe lambert ce que je reçois
bonjour bonjour vous êtes co président
du groupe des verts vous êtes vous vient
de débuter belge au sein de ce parlement
et vous fait surtout partie de la
fameuse commission econ commission des
affaires économiques
philippe lambertz quand on entend un
petit peu cet édito de simon barbarie
est-ce que vous avez confiance dans la
commission dans sa capacité à mettre en
place cette fameuse transparence le dise
au point confiance limitée surtout quand
on voit ce qu'ils ne se trouvent pas
dans ce parce qu'ils appellent ce
premier paquet fiscal a un paquet qui se
résume à un article d'une directive et à
l'article qu'il est proposé de changer
mais qui requiert l'unanimité des états
membres autrement dit pour que les états
membres acceptent de se communiquer les
uns aux autres des informations sûres et
ruling fiscaux qu'ils octroient aux
grandes entreprises donc les ruling pour
être clair donc c'est ce qui a changé en
la paix d'une ayant je le dis c'est
comme ça les arrangements à la tête du
client qu'on octroie aux grandes
entreprises eh bien il faudra encore
l'unanimité des états membres pour
adopter la mesure donc on en est encore
loin une autre mesure aurait pu être
proposées par la commission et ne l'a
pas été et c'est la mesure qui oblige
les entreprises multinationales a publié
dans le rapport annuel c'est à dire
publiquement leurs résultats principaux
chiffres d'affaires profite taxes payées
nombre de personnes employées pays par
pays et c'est ce genre d'information
évidemment qui est très gênant pour les
grandes entreprises de publier penser
encore à ce cas d'un mcdonald's dont on
découvre qu'une filiale luxembourgeoise
fait 4 milliard de chiffre d'affaires
chaque année sur lequel ils payent
quelques millions d'euros de taxe et ils
font tout ça tenez vous bien avec 13
personnes et bien c'est le jeu c'est le
genre de chose qui quand elles sont
révélés gêne très fort les
multinationales c'est ce genre de
mesures là aussi c'est une mesure qui
consiste en un article wayne directives
et je constate que la commission
européenne n'a pas eu le courage
politique elle n'envisage tout fait la
position du parlement dont vous nous
parlez là alors c'est la position que le
parlement adopte et que et que nous
avons en tout cas en commission
économique et monétaire c'est une
obligation qui s'impose depuis le 1er
janvier à toutes les banques qui opèrent
de manière multinationales mais pas à
toutes les multinationales de tous les
secteurs donc vous voulez en fait
élargir la exacte des entreprises
concernées c'est la position du
parlement elle a été votée par votre
commission alors elle pour être votées
en commission des affaires juridiques au
mois de mai une j'espère en tout cas
qu'il se trouvera ici qu'avec une
majorité pour adopter la mesure je ne
comprends pas comment est ce que on peut
justifier cette absence de transparence
il s'agit que de transparence et et on
verra si la commission dans son paquet
du mois de juin aux rejoindre cette
proposition moi j'attends de voir donc
de toutes façons si jamais c'est voté au
mois de mai par l'autre commission et
votez donc si c'est officiellement la
position du parlement à terme on sera
dans de la codécision donc on se rendant
de la connexion vous allez pouvoir
oeuvrer auprès de la commission et du
conseil pour obtenir ça absolument ou
est ce que vous sentez ce que je les lui
quand même à plusieurs reprises il ya
quand même une volonté il ya un lobby
qui se met en place chez les grandes
entreprises pour complètement bloquer
votre position énorme énorme évidemment
ce lobby est très discret parce que
publiquement il est en fait impossible
de justifier
le refus de cette transparence alors on
va dire oui mais vous comprenez ça m'a
demandé beaucoup de travail aux
multinationales et je viens de
multinationales ces chiffres les
multinationales elles les ont deux on va
dire oui mais enfin ça sera mauvais pour
leur compétitivité expliquez-moi
pourrait y a absolument aucune raison
que de la transparence en usi la
compétitivité je dirais même aux
ultralibéraux parmi nous que la doctrine
libérale veut que le marché soit
parfaitement trouvé et que tous les
acteurs ici l'information donc plus
d'informations ne peut pas être mauvais
en réalité l'argument qui est utilisé
par les multinationales mais là derrière
des portes fermées quand elle rencontre
des députés les commissaires ou des
ministres vous comprenez bien si on
devait publier ses informations ce
serait nuisible à notre réputation aa et
justement ça et donc elles savent très
bien que l chipote avec les avec les
lois fiscales et n'ont pas envie que ça
se sache et la première étape si on veut
combattre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale
c'est justement la transparence tiger en
termes de réputation ça vous oblige à
faire un petit peu ce que vous dites
soyons clair philippe lambert vous nous
parliez de mcdonald's de tout à l'heure
on connaît le cas d'apple on connaît le
cas d'amazon etc on sait qu'il ya eu
alors d'aucuns diraient malversations
d'autres disent forme d'évasion fiscale
déguisée ou mais est-ce que ça empêche
est ce que le consommateur que vous
n'êtes que nous sommes sales empêche
d'aller consommer au mcdonald's aller
acheter des produits apple pas vraiment
c'est sûr que l'effet direct sur le
consommateur est limité néanmoins
néanmoins il y a un effet lorsque le new
york times a fait sa série sur le fait
que apple employés des enfants en chine
apple a été mal pris lorsque le même
apple a été convoqué au congrès des
états unis pour expliquer pourquoi il
parc 170 milliards de profits dans des
paradis fiscaux pour éviter l'impôt des
sociétés ça gêne et apple aux
entournures deux entreprises sont
sensibles à leur réputation et donc moi
ce que j'espère c'est qu'en effet plus
il y aura de transparence plus le
consommateur
modifiera ses choix en fonction en
fonction de cela et nous allons voir
avec les banques en tout cas mais nous
allons faire en sorte que les
informations publiées pays par pays soit
en tout cas largement diffusé bon en
attendant il ya autre chose qui occupe
bien permis pierre moscovici en ce
moment c'est la question de la grèce je
voudrais qu'on écoute qu'il a déclaré il
y a encore quelques jours
nous soutenons pleinement l'objectif
d'aider les plus vulnérables dans la
société grecque ceux qui ont été frappés
par la crise les autorités grecques
doivent travailler de façon constructive
avec les institutions avec la commission
avec la banque centrale avec le fonds
monétaire international ce qui implique
qu'il y ait des consultations sur des
nouvelles mesures
philippe lambas quand vous entendez
pierre moscovici dire il faut que la
grèce travail de manière constructive
avec les institutions là
pour nous qui sommes des observateurs
moyen de ce qui se passe on en est dans
un feuilleton saison 4 épisode 18 on le
comprend absolument plus rien ou est-ce
qu'on en est ce dossier est ce qu'on va
réussir à sauver ce qui reste à sauver
est-ce qu'on est encore dans de la
négociation ou est-ce qu'on en laye mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on soit dans la
négociation ça fait maintenant plus de
deux mois que les élections grecs ont eu
lieu on a l'impression que le
gouvernement grec n'a pas encore compris
que la campagne électorale est terminée
et donc je peux comprendre que c'est un
nouveau gouvernement que le niveau que
les nerfs sont à fleur de peau angoisse
parce qu'on a l'impression à juste titre
d'avoir été colonisé par la troîka ceci
étant dans l'intérêt des citoyens à
greek dans l'intérêt politique de syriza
il faut trouver un accord il faut
trouver un accord et donc la grèce un
accord ce n'est pas la grèce qui impose
quelque chose à ses créanciers c'est
plus quelques les créanciers qui impose
à la grèce il faut un moment s'asseoir
autour d'une table et discuter
concrètement chiffres délais et mesure
concrète n'est pas le cas à la bouille
apparemment apparemment ces discussions
ont grand mal à démarrer je veux dire on
discute beaucoup de la nasa fait de
moins en fait qu'on est dans des
postures et qu'on est né gaulle a pas
finalement je vous avais dit le mot il
s'agit de posture il s'agit de beaucoup
de gesticulations et d'un côté comme de
l'autre d'ailleurs moi quand je vois le
débat en allemagne s'est beaucoup de
gesticulations aussi j'aimerais bien
qu'on arrête de parler j'aimerais bien
qu'on ne parle plus de la grèce et qu'en
fait les discussions aient lieu
discrètement de manière à trouver un
accord et les contours de cet accord son
aide mais quand s'agit pour le
gouvernement grec de proposer quelques
mesures comptait justement c'est ça que
j'allais vous diront ça fait deux mois
qu'on attendait un calendrier de
réformes concret qu'on n'a toujours pas
semblé très exactement et donc en
échange d'engagements concrets de la
grèce notamment à mettre en place un
système de collecte d'un collectif
fiscale digne de ce nom est là dessus de
la grèce a besoin d' aide extérieure
sans que ce soit colonisait et
clairement il faut une aide européenne
il faut une aide effet mis pour mettre
tout cela en place et en échange les
européens doivent alors donné un ballon
d'oxygène financière la grèce c'est à
dire de lui donner de quoi s'occuper du
sort des plus démunis en grèce rappelle
que 3,5 millions de citoyens grecs n'ont
pas accès aux soins de santé oms un pays
de l'union européenne c'est pas normal
ce sont des conditions du tiers-monde et
puis le chômage a augmenté de 25% fin la
connaît les chiffres depuis la crise
donc on sait très bien quels sont les
termes de l'accord mais simplement
maintenant il faut se mettre à le
discuter et ce qui me revient c'est
qu'en effet jusqu'à maintenant le
gouvernement grec n'a pas comment n'a
pas accepté de se mettre autour de la
table pour discuter très concrètement
des choses donc écouter nous suivrons ce
feuilleton c'est un petit peu notre
house of cards mais allah allah à
l'européenne merci beaucoup philippe
dans l'art d'avoir été avec nous on
continue direction la suède depuis les
attentats de paris et de copenhague la
communauté juive vit dans un climat
d'insécurité permanent et beaucoup se
demandent aujourd'hui s'ils ne vont pas
faire leur alyah ce retour ou du moins
ce départ vers israël pour retrouver une
forme de sécurité nous avons été à la
rencontre de cette communauté qui vit un
petit peu caché c'est un reportage à
malmö de paul bouffard
chaque matin le même rituel déborah et
six mois en mènent leur fils à l'école
un rituel perturbé sur le chemin ils
sont sur leurs gardes par précaution ils
ont souhaité garder l'anonymat
la famille est de confession juive
la différence maintenant c'est qu'on ne
peut plus rester devant l'école juive on
est plus en sécurité
je ne m'attaque plus ici je fais vite je
dépose notre enfant et m'assure que la
porte est bien refermer derrière moi
ça fait vraiment bizarre de savoir que
notre enfant n'est plus en sécurité
juste parce qu'il est juif
une école juive une centaine d'enfants
sous haute protection policière en plein
centre de malmö la troisième ville de
suède
ici on est à quelques kilomètres de
copenhague au danemark il ya quelques
semaines deux attaques terroristes
bouleverse le pays la seconde vise une
synagogue danoise en plein shabbat un
agent de sécurité tué depuis en suède on
renforce la sécurité devant les
institutions juives des policiers
suréquipés sont déployés
rise elle est enseignante ici à l'école
depuis les attentats plusieurs parents
ont retiré leurs enfants de
l'établissement sert à quatre clients
qui ont signé les papiers donc ils ont
inscrit leur enfant entre paris-nord un
bon 2 qui ne sont pas encore revenus je
pense que c'est la peur
devenir dans une école de police on sait
qu'en suède les écoles maternelles les
écoles primaires rien n'est fermé tout
est ouvert enfin des sorties scolaires
les enfants sont cloîtrés à l'intérieur
des classes ils ne vont même plus à la
bibliothèque l'insécurité grandit devant
l'école hors caméra une mère de famille
nous interpelle elle nous le confie sa
peur et si grande qu'elle prévoit de
quitter la suède pour israël d'ici
quinze jours
malmö ces trois cent mille habitants le
symbole du multiculturalisme à la
suédoise où se côtoient près de 175
communautés différentes
un exemple de vivre ensemble une société
ouverte et sur qui voit l'antisémitisme
grandir face à ce constat s'est adjoint
au maire a dû prendre des mesures
particulières
surveillance la caméra bien sûr
des gardes de sécurité devant les juifs
devant la synagogue c'est bien sûr la
toute première chose qu on devait faire
et je vais faire dans l'urgence ensuite
dans un second temps et vient à plus
long terme on doit sensibiliser les
jeunes à l'antisémitisme
bien sûr ça prend du temps mais ce temps
est vraiment le prends un peu
au stade de malmö séances de
sensibilisation aux religions vous savez
qui est sur la photo
jésus oui mais il ya quelqu'un d'autre
avec lui résident soit là bas il ya
aussi judas d'astuces des dizaines de
jeunes toutes confessions confondues
sont réunies le comité suédois contre
l'antisémitisme se mobilisent il faut
mettre des mots sur le racisme
souvent l'antisémitisme est suggéré
sous-entendu il faut que les professeurs
et enseignants soient capables de parler
de ça qu'il soit capable de contrer ses
idées ils ont besoin des connaissances
de base comme dans l'antisémitisme se
propage aujourd'hui et notamment sur
internet les jeunes passent beaucoup de
temps
le rabbin kesselman subit régulièrement
des attaques il y encore deux jours les
prises à partie par des jeunes qui
l'insultent en pleine rue mais pour le
leader de la communauté de malmö pas
question de céder pas question de se
cacher
beaucoup de juifs ont le sentiment de
voir renforcer leur identité juive
engagement et leur croyance la tradition
que pense-t-il du premier ministre
israélien benyamin nétanyahou qui
appelle les juifs d'europe à faire leur
alya leur retour en israël pour trouver
la sécurité
je pense qu'il fait son travail de
premier ministre en informant les juifs
sont un endroit sécurisé venir vivre
je pense que c'est une sonnette d'alarmé
pour les communautés européennes
il y à une communauté juive
mon sentiment c'est que nous avons une
responsabilité
comme rabat comme leader de la
communauté je dois être un exemple
je dois résister je dois me lever tous
les droits de la communauté juive je ne
céderait jamais devant les forces du mal
aujourd'hui il y aurait environ 1500
suédois de confession juive à malmö en
2014 la police a enregistré 137 plainte
pour antisémitisme une augmentation de
30% sur les deux dernières années
s'agit-il donc d'un regain ou
l'antisémitisme n'at-il jamais vraiment
disparu de l'espace européen pour
répondre à ces questions c'est joël
rubinfeld que je reçois bonjour je vous
êtes président de la ligue belge contre
l'antisémitisme et younousse omarjee
bonjour vous êtes des bontés de front
front gauche et président de la
délégation française de ce groupe ici au
sein de ce parlement tu voi rubinfeld
quelle est votre lecture de cette de
cette situation à malmö mais qui est la
même dans la plupart des communautés
juives d'europe malmö c'est le point
zéro de l'antisémitisme en europe ce qui
s'est passé là-bas est assez dramatique
et probablement que la communauté juive
à malmö est voué à disparaître à émigrer
vers des cieux plus accueillants c'est
un sens ça représente oui et il ya eu
déjà un exode assez important depuis une
dizaine d'années entre autres à cause à
cause du maire de malmö ilmar reepalu
l'ancien maire un maire de gauche qui a
tenu des propos assez
assez comment dire incendiaires
justement sur ce conflit et sur la forme
d'antisémitisme contemporain parce que
l'antisémitisme est un virus qui mute
qui s'adapte à son environnement
la première grande phase de
l'antisémitisme ce que j'appellerais
l'antisémitisme 1.0 c'est l'anti
judaïsme sur une base religieuse qui a
sévi pendant 16 17 siècle puis ça a
évolué au siècle précédent au 19ème
siècle vers l'antisémitisme sur base
raciale qui s'appelait d'ailleurs
antisémitisme aujourd'hui depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale à la sortie de
la seconde guerre mondiale il était plus
politiquement correct d'ailleurs
légalement c'est aussi répréhensible
d'être antisémite et donc cette nous
sommes dans si vous voulez le dernier
avatar de l'antisémitisme lentilles
minutes 3.0 qui a un autre nom qui est
l'anti sionisme qui a substitué l'état
juif à l'individu juif et il est impec
alors là quand vous nous parlez
d'antisionisme soyons clairs c'est on
n'est pas d'accord avec la politique
menée par israël mais est ce que pour
autant ne pas être d'accord avec la
politique israélienne c'est remettre en
question la présence des juifs sur le
territoire européen s'il n'y a pas
d'annoncé on parle pas de la même chose
vous dire critiquer la politique
israélienne s'est bien entendu ça fait
partie du débat tout à fait acceptable
et démocratique
tickets la politique israël n est pas
être antisémite sinon on pourrait
considérer que la majorité de la
population israélienne elle-même et
antisémites ont bien entendu que ce
n'est pas le cas je crois que ce genre
de discours vient aggraver au fond les
fractures et il faut laisser aux
commerces aux agrès écoutez écoutez nous
sommes engagés à la gauche unitaire
européenne
pour les droits du peuple palestinien
j'en reviens d'ailleurs d'une mission en
israël et en palestine et ce sont des
sentiments de paix de justice d'égalité
qui nous conduisent dans ce combat et
nous refusons ce terrorisme intellectuel
qui fait de nous des deux anti sémite
présumé les juifs d'europe sont ici chez
eux les juifs de france sont en france
chez eux et nous devons tout faire pour
leur apporter la sécurité et le respect
qu'il mérite vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire qu'on peut critiquer la
politique israélienne et vous comme moi
je pense que nous sommes pour une
solution pacifique au moyen orient à
savoir deux peuples pour deux états pour
deux peuples maintenant le lien c'est
pas moi qui le fais le maire de malmö
ilmar est pas lui qui en 2010 lorsqu'il
était questionné sur l'explosion de
l'antisémitisme dans sa propre ville a
dit lui même je le cite dans le scan
scadd dagbladet il dit à malmö nous
n'acceptons ni l'antisémitisme ni le
sionisme donc lui-même fait seul un a au
delà de ça je voudrais citer votre
premier ministre monsieur manuel valls
qui lui-même disait derrière un
antisionisme de façade c'est
l'antisémitisme et la haine du juif qui
se cache donc si on veut vraiment si on
veut vraiment traiter le problème il
faut aller à la racine du problème est
la racine c'est la substitution de
l'état juif à l'individu juifs à ce
propos il y avait les dictateurs que
nous avons rencontrés dans le cadre de
ce reportage qui avait une question à
vous poser en écoute
l'antisémitisme est un réel problème
aujourd'hui partout en europe un
problème qui s'accentue
selon vous qu'est ce qui peut être
réalisé pour le contrer et pour
sensibiliser la population à
l'antisémitisme et combattre sa
propagation
alors clairement maintenant on va parler
de comment on agit est-ce qu'il s'agit
juste de faire des grands discours en
disant il faut recréer du lien social
retravaillé retisser du lien entre les
communautés pour que ça marche pas sur
les mines à elle une politique de
tolérance zéro et frantz fanon lui-même
disait lorsqu'on parle d'un juif temps
l'aurait parce qu'on parle de toi il
n'ya rien de plus ressemblant au sourire
grimaçant d'un raciste anti juif que le
sourire les masses en d'un raciste anti
musulman ou anti noir donc les choses
sont très claires là dessus mais pour
cerner le problème il faut nommer le mal
et c'est là que nous avons une
divergence importante c'est sûr
justement cette nouvelle forme
d'antisémitisme un antisémitisme 3.0 je
ne remet pas du tout en cause votre
bonne foi et votre bonne volonté pour
lutter comme ça contre cela mais lorsque
par exemple nous avons nous ne pas fait
donc le premier tour des élections en
france et nous avons par exemple un
candidat du front de gauche monsieur
assène des kills donc qu'ils étaient
candidats à marseille et qui a fait 8%
au premier tour
lorsque vous allez voir ses propos sa
pensée et bien lui-même exprime ce lien
entre l'antisémitisme et l'antisionisme
lorsque le voit sur son mur facebook
juste un exemple j'en ai trois mais je
vais donner un exemple des dizaines
d'esclaves du sionisme mondial entre
parenthèses dahesh avec trois étoiles de
david à côté liquidée par les kurdes
syriens dont il est là le problème
nous on a actuellement une convergence
entre l'antisémitisme d'extrême droite
et l'antisémitisme l'extrême gauche
lorsque le président est en train de
faire une alliance rouge brun en gros
mais c'est pas moi qui l'a fait c'est si
alain soral alain soral justin comme un
petit exemple alain soral pied
locke de l'extrême droite pur et dur
dépassé par le parti communiste puis par
le front national lorsque je vois sur le
site d'alain sorin mais non monsieur
mélange
homogène au fond il faut nommer l'assaut
problème monsieur répond sinon ça ne
serait maintenant j'aimerais bien qu'on
revienne sur le fond on s'adresse ici à
des populations de jeunes gens vous
l'avez précise le montage qui
aujourd'hui souffrent d'une défiance
vis-à-vis d'autres communautés comment
est-ce qu'on crée du lien entre ces
connaissez vous êtes en train de nous
parler bon de certains politiques
d'alain soral qui ne fait pas parler
précisément est-ce qu'on recrée ce lien
précisément nous avons des liens en ont
le mal ce temps que vous savez si on
essaie de traiter un patient malade et
que vous allez au bras alors qu'il faut
le traiter à la tête eh bien ce ne
seront que des emplâtres sur une jambe
de bois il faut aller là-bas le problème
et l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui en europe
occidentale qui sévit ces sept ans si
sémitisme qui s'alimentent comme le dit
manuel valls qui s'alimentent de la
haine du juif s'alimente de la haine
d'israël
je vais tenter de les tenter de répondre
à votre question pour sortir de ces
raisonnements un peu spécieux je pouvais
le coeur je vous en prie je vous pourrez
par exemple dire qu'il ya une
convergence
aujourd'hui entre ceux qui sont des
partisans acharnés
des de la lutte contre les palestiniens
et des mouvements d'extrême droite et
qui participe à une islamophobie c'est
un raisonnement que je ne tiens pas et
sa taille en cela je pense qu'elle
n'existe pas et il n'y a pas en tout cas
chez nous au front de gauche d'alliance
de cette nature pour répondre à votre
question nous avons les mêmes références
intellectuelle et philosophique
cette phrase de frantz fanon elle est
absolument formidable bond et je pense
qu'on pourrait aussi la décliner sous
d'autres formes bon et dire aux juifs
par exemple que lorsqu'on attaque un
noir ces deux également dont on parle le
problème qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il faut apporter de la culture et de
l'éducation partout dans les quartiers
en difficulté mais aussi ailleurs c'est
par la culture et l'éducation qu'il sera
possible de lutter en france par exemple
puisque c'est le pays que je connais le
mieux on a retiré les moyens de
l'éducation populaire bon eh bien nous
voyons aujourd'hui le résultat il y a
souvent une indigence intellectuelle
contre laquelle il faut lutter et puis
il y a aussi une ignorance de la
religion de l'autre on porte l'autre de
la religion comporte soi même bon les
musulmans comme les juifs comme les
chrétiens devraient être animés par
cette idée que nous procédons tous du
même socle commun bon moi même mon
prénom c'est yunus mais c'est jonas
également je viens d'un pays où
voyez-vous l'île de la réunion un client
d'un exemple je pense pour le monde
entier dans le dialogue culturel et
religieux et interreligieux et je dois
vous dire que lorsque je suis en europe
je suis assez effaré et je me dis que
notre petite île et j'aimerais des
exemples est sans doute un peu plus
civilisée sur bien des plans dernière
question monsieur parce qu'on arrive à
l'issue de ce débat est ce que il faudra
en passer par le règlement du conflit au
proche orient pour réussir à trouver une
solution à ses retentissements en europe
2 millions d'européens juifs ne sont pas
tributaires d'événements qui se passe à
4000 km d'ici donc on souhaite tout ce
qu'il y ait un règlement rapide de ce
conflit mais nous ne pouvons pas être
pris en otage par les forces obscures au
proche orient que ce soit lors hamas ou
le hezbollah qui ne veulent pas d'un
règlement du conflit et je voudrais
juste terminer ma mon intervention en
disant ah monsieur marc j sais que je
sais qu'au front de gauche est un peu
partout il y à des baux toute bonne
volonté pour traiter ce problème
normalement dans l'adn du front de
gauche et de l'extrême gauche il devrait
avoir la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
mais nous sommes un choix crucial
aujourd'hui et ce choix crucial c'est
choisir entre aides pompiers ou
pyromanes il est évident aussi que la
politique des sram droite de monsieur
netanyahou n'est pas de nature extrême
droit à apaiser les tensions partout
lorsque le monsieur lieberman fait des
déclarations comme quoi il faut
décapiter à la hache les arabes le
premier tour effectif c'est le nom
d'alain roche à la cool devant joint là
dessus c'est un jour sans entendue dans
toute l'europe et que cela ne participe
pas du tout à calmer la situation sa
présence ces propos sont scandaleux vous
avez tout à fait raison je vous rejoins
là dessus maintenant une fois traduisant
les belges les européens juifs ne sont
pas tributaires de ce qui se passe là
bas comme les chinois ne sont pas
tributaires de l'occupation du tibet
solucom destrumelle sont pas tributaires
de leur diversité exactement et comme
les musulmans de france et d'europe ne
sont pas tributaires de ce qui se passe
actuelle a drôlement dans le moyen
orient en irak en syrie et en libye et
ce sont ces amalgames qui ne doivent pas
être rapidement non plus et dénoncer
merci beaucoup merci monsieur bah
écoutez on suivra bien entendu cette
situation merci à tous rendez vous la
semaine prochaine avec katia ici au
parlement européen ciao
hu